today the multilateral rules-based order
is on the threat and is precisely why we
are strengthening our EU United Nations
cooperation and this is why Secretary
General Gutierrez joined our European
council meeting last week
our discussions focus on three topics
the war in Ukraine climate change and
reforming the Global Financial system
Russia is attacking Ukraine and
attacking our International rules-based
System
but the multilateral system is resisting
and standing firm the U.N has played a
key role in finding Concrete Solutions
on humanitarian support refugees on the
Black Sea grain initiative and on
neutral facilities
the EU and United Nations also cooperate
on many Global issues such as climate
change and for instance we have seen
recently with the historic agreement on
the high seas treaty
the 27 youth leaders also we have found
their commitment
to the 2030 agenda and its sustainable
development doors and we discussed the
importance of reforming the Global
Financial system to fight poverty and to
make the world fairer
ladies and gentlemen prison zelinski has
addressed every European Council since
the start of the war and last week was
no exception
made one thing very clear to defend
himself Ukraine needs more weapons and
more ammunition we endorsed the decision
on ammunition agreed by the 21st Council
we acted strictly it took barely six
weeks after prime minister kelas
proposed the idea and when we tasked the
high representative who is taking it
Forward our goal is to provide one
million rounds of ammunition within the
next 12 months the European peace
facility and European Defense Agency
will help to get it done and this joint
EU initiative constitutes a major new
step towards the genuine European
Defense
we also discussed the recent
international criminal trials decision
this is the beginning of a process to
hold Russian leaders accountable for
their crimes in Ukraine and we also
agreed to step up efforts along with our
partners to prevent the circumvention
and Battery link of our sanctions
ladies and gentlemen
yesterday I was in Moldova where we
shared the Houston message of solidarity
with the moldovans we also prepared the
student meeting of the European public
Community which will take place in
chisino on June 1st Moldova is under
growing pressure from Russia it needs
our support we have mobilized over 1
billion euros in the past year to
support its resilience and stability and
we are ready to do more that's why we've
invited the permission to present a
support package for Moldova before
summer
ladies and gentlemen dear cholis we also
had an important debate on our long-term
competitiveness and we agreed to focus
on three areas first building smarter
regulation we need to make life easier
for our businesses and create conditions
for our businesses to flourish right
here in the EU and it means cutting red
tape faster permitting shorter deadlines
easier procedures and digital Solutions
students unlocking investment to ensure
our long-term competitiveness we need
massive investments in Technology
Innovation connectivity
silencing is the lifeblood of our
European businesses especially our smes
so we need to make it easier for them to
get the private capital and investment
they need to innovate scale up and
Thrive and we have the financial means
at our disposal savings represent 1.5
trillion Euros in the European Union the
Capital Market Union will help make this
happen it's time to speed up work and
get this done
and third Point boosting research and
Innovation the EU needs to become a
Powerhouse of innovation especially in
areas with tremendous gross potential
like renewable and clean tech we will
therefore increase investment in r d
help Innovative products and services
get on the markets
we also discussed trade essential to our
prosperity
since 1950s trade has grown from 5 to 25
percent of our GDP and we need to
consider a number of issues to it is
influenced by geopolitics and with
navigate our trade relations in this
complex landscape in relation to the U.S
U.S we are a close and strategic Ally in
recent months we have discussed our
economic cooperation notably on the IAA
and the WTO re form we are working
together with the United States to find
a solution to the issues raised by the
IRA
as for China we Face the reality as it
is today China is a major trading
partner and has become more assertive
and more challenging so we need to be
clear on our goal we want to deal with
not to decouple it's also important to
maintain a multilateral trade system
with a reformed World Trade Organization
at its core and this includes its
dispute settlement mechanism the 27
leaders agreed to continue our ambitious
trade agenda while defending our
interests
on migration we continue the reward from
last month's Summit we are implementing
the concrete measures addressed and the
council presidency and the commission
updated us on the progress so far we
will continue our work on this it's a
priority for us all
dear colleagues we also held on Friday a
Euro Summit to the participation of
tresin ladard and passion and this
meeting focused on two key points first
the current economic and financial
situation
our economies entered 2023 on a
healthier footing than expected but the
impact on inflation remains a serious
concern and we agreed to continue to
closely coordinate our Economic Policy
responses and we also reiterated that
the economy governance framework is key
for a strong economic and monetary Union
sudden we focused on our European
Financial architecture
our banking secretary Switzerland
Western capital and liquidity positions
and the banking Union has significantly
strengthened our resilience but we
should not be complacent we therefore
called for continued efforts to complete
our banking Union
speeding a progress on the Capital
Market unions is also a top priority
the EU is a storm defender of
multilateralism and the rules-based
international order will continue to
work to make Europe stronger and most of
rain and to make the world a fairer
place for everyone I thank you
thank you very much president Michelle I
give the flow now to the president of
the European commission rules of
underline
thank you very much president Roberta
president Michelle
honorable members
indeed we had
a lot of topics on the agenda in the
last European Council I want to focus on
three of them
and the centerpiece was certainly
competitiveness with the view of our
response to the inflation reduction act
you are very familiar with the backdrop
so we discussed how to answer to the
inflation reduction act you know what's
on the table the first part is the
negotiated part you know that with our
American friends we under confirmed our
understanding that European carmakers
get access to the U.S market and to U.S
tax breaks with leased electric vehicles
the second part is that is negotiated on
critical raw materials for batteries
where we are looking for an agreement
that will ensure that critical minerals
for batteries that are extracted and
processed here in the European Union are
treated equally to those from Canada and
Mexico for example as if we had a free
trade agreement and third President
Biden and I established a transparency
Dialogue on the cleantech subsidies
this is one part this is the negotiated
part but the bigger and more important
part is that we have to do our homework
here in the European Union
we know that today European companies
are leaders in NetZero research and
innovation
and we have set ourselves very ambitious
targets for the deployment of Renewables
however
our policies have a gap
and that is the support for
manufacturing of clean Technologies
you all know this situation that with
the moment a new technology
moves to commercial deployment at scale
so really scaling up that's just the
moment where manufacturing often moves
outside the European Union
and we know that China is the largest
producer of all mass manufactured clean
tech so from batteries to solar panels
from certain types of electrolyzers to
heat pumps and this is especially
concerning
because according to the International
Energy agency
Renewables will account for over 90
percent of global electricity expansion
in the next five years
in other words
China will be the biggest winner of this
expansion and if we do not act right now
this Chinese dominance of a clean tech
value chain will become even more not
less pronounced
this is why the commission has put
forward two acts acts the one is the Net
Zero industry Act and the other one is
the critical raw materials Act
we discussed the Net Zero industry act
it will create a regulatory environment
that is conducive to scaling up the
clean tech industry in Europe so just
the Gap that we have right now to fill
this Gap to really encourage to scale up
and this is combined with European
funding or stated both possibilities are
possible
and with a matching Clause so that we
have transparency on what happens on the
American Market
in other words The Net Zero industry act
aims at keeping European companies in
Europe and not see them emigrate across
the Atlantic or to China
the second element we discussed is the
proposal of the critical raw materials
act on the table now
we all know that the critical raw
materials are vital for twin transition
that is the decarbonization as well as
digitalization
and while the demand for new re for
these raw materials is projected to
increase drastically
we know that Europe heavily depends on
import
and of course this dependency that we
have on import threatens not only our
climate and digital objectives
but it also weakens our industrial base
therefore
the critical raw material acts aims at
significantly to improve the conditions
for extracting processing and very
important the recycling of these
critical raw materials here in the
European Union
and at the same time we're strengthening
our cooperation with reliable Partners
around the world so be it zinc or nickel
from Canada or lithium from Chile
deputy
Monday
foreign
founder
not representative
foreign
European
[Applause]
Epp group to the chairman
president Michelle
I first of all want to thank the Swedish
presidency the top priority of this
council meeting was competitiveness and
this was so urgently needed in the last